This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. We all love a good surprise. In movies, we love the moment when the rug is pulled out from under us. When everything we thought we knew, turns out to be totally wrong. We love these moments so much, we even get a kick out of watching other people being surprised. WHAAAA! My God! Oh my God! In fact, there's an entire mini genre on YouTube of parents filming their children with them as they watch one of the greatest surprise scenes in movie history.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们都喜欢惊喜。在电影里，我们喜欢那种被“釜底抽薪”的时刻，喜欢那种我们自以为知晓一切，结果却发现完全错了的时刻。我们太喜欢这些时刻了，甚至以观看别人被惊吓为乐。哇！天哪！天哪！事实上，YouTube上有一个专门的迷你流派，记录父母拍摄孩子观看电影史上最伟大惊喜场景时的反应。
Spoiler alert, this is the showdown between our tribe's Darth Vader and Luke Skywalker in Star Wars the Empire Strikes Back. Video after video shows cute little kids peeking out from under blankets, their eyes wide as they discover the secret that the rest of the world already knows. I am your father. What? Does there is this father? Daddy is that true?
剧透预警，这是《星球大战：帝国反击战》中我们部落的达斯·维达和卢克·天行者的对决。视频里，可爱的孩子们从毯子下探出头，当他们发现那个全世界都已经知道的秘密时，眼睛瞪得大大的。我是你的父亲。什么？这是真的吗？爸爸，那是真的吗？
It's totally true. What? That just plays as father. This week we'll find out why our tendency to be easily fooled in movies can reveal something important about the way our minds work outside the movie theater. Stories do what happens to us as we make our way through the world all the time. We're making inferences, we're trying to make sense of the world and understand what other people think, what other people know, what's going on, and what stories do is they
完全是真的。什么？这只是扮演父亲。本周我们将探讨为什么我们在电影中容易被愚弄的倾向，能揭示出我们大脑在电影院之外运作方式的一些重要信息。故事在我们行走于世的过程中不断地影响着我们。我们一直在进行推断，试图理解这个世界，理解他人的想法、他人的认知以及正在发生的事情。而故事所做的就是
play on these tendencies and they exploit them to produce really piratechnic effects. We'll talk to Vera Tobin, a cognitive scientist at Case Western Reserve University. She's the author of Elements of Surprise, our mental limits and the satisfaction of plot. We're going to look at two movies from the 1990s, the sixth sense and the usual suspects. If you haven't seen those movies yet, fair warning, more spoilers are coming your way. What do you think? We think what? Do you think that's crazy?
利用这些倾向，并利用它们产生非常惊人的效果。我们将与凯斯西储大学的认知科学家维拉·托宾交谈。她是《惊喜的要素：我们的心理极限与情节的满足感》一书的作者。我们将审视两部20世纪90年代的电影：《第六感》和《非常嫌疑犯》。如果你还没看过这些电影，友情提醒，剧透即将来袭。你觉得怎么样？我们觉得什么？你觉得那很疯狂吗？
Yeah. Storytellers are not neuroscientists, but they intuitively know what neuroscientists know. All of us have blind spots in the way we assess the world. We overlook key details. We forget how we know things. We see patterns that aren't there. Because these blind spots are wired into the brain, they act in ways that are predictable. So predictable that storytellers from Sophocles to M. Night Shyamalan have used them against us to lead us astray. In recent years, some scientists have begun to ask, can stories serve as a kind of brains can?
是的。讲故事的人不是神经科学家，但他们凭直觉就知道神经科学家所了解的东西。我们在评估世界时都有盲点。我们忽略了关键细节，忘记了我们是如何知道某些事情的，我们看到了并不存在的模式。因为这些盲点植根于大脑，它们的行为方式是可预测的。这种可预测性让从索福克勒斯到M·奈特·沙马兰这样的讲故事者能够利用它们来误导我们。近年来，一些科学家开始问：故事能成为一种大脑扫描仪吗？
If a surprise ending works by exploiting our biases and mental shortcuts, can observing the mechanics of a good story reveal something important about the contours of the mind? As we make our way through the world, our brains are assembling very fragmented, jagged bits of information into a coherent story for us, and what stories, films, and novels, and so on are doing is capitalizing on these features, and because they're doing that, it provides a wonderful sort of laboratory in the wild, you might say, for identifying where people are making those inferences, what kinds of predictable sorts of projections they make to fill in those gaps because the stories are exposing them.
如果一个惊喜结局是通过利用我们的偏见和心理捷径来起作用的，那么观察一个好故事的机制能否揭示出大脑轮廓的一些重要信息？当我们行走于世时，我们的大脑正在将非常零碎、参差不齐的信息片段组装成一个连贯的故事。而故事、电影、小说等所做的，正是利用这些特征。正因为如此，它们提供了一个绝佳的“野外实验室”，可以用来识别人们在何处进行推断，以及他们为了填补空白而做出的那种可预测的投射，因为故事将这些暴露了出来。
If the idea of using movies as a brain scan seems far-fetched, think about what scientists have learned in recent years by studying magic tricks. So, you're going to be holding the coin like this, boom. This is a popular YouTube magician known as the Russian Genius. For this I will be showing you a coin, Venice, which looks something like this. In this clip, which we've altered a bit for clarity, he puts a coin in his left hand, gives it a dramatic squeeze, boom, and opens his hand.
如果把电影当作大脑扫描仪的想法听起来有些牵强，想想科学家们近年来通过研究魔术学到了什么。所以，你要像这样拿着硬币，砰。这是一位在YouTube上很受欢迎的魔术师，被称为“俄罗斯天才”。为了这个，我将向你们展示一枚硬币，威尼斯，看起来像这样。在这个我们为了清晰起见稍作修改的片段中，他把一枚硬币放在左手里，用力一挤，砰，然后张开了手。
And then it just disappears just like that. In fact, the coin is whisked away by the magician's other hand when we're not looking. But at this point, our minds have already filled in the gaps about cause and effect. That little squeeze of the hand, boom, it seems like it made the coin actually disappear. In this way a good magician exploits gaps in our attention and our tendency to draw rapid but flawed inferences.
然后它就这样消失了。事实上，当我们不注意的时候，硬币被魔术师的另一只手拿走了。但在这一点上，我们的大脑已经填补了关于因果关系的空白。那轻轻一挤，砰，看起来确实让硬币消失了。通过这种方式，一位优秀的魔术师利用了我们注意力的空隙，以及我们做出快速但有缺陷的推断的倾向。
In fact there's a whole thriving sub-area of cognitive science that has realized that magic tricks are this really fertile ground for discovering things about limitations in our visual perception and aspects of our attention that magicians have capitalized on for decades and centuries even. And the kinds of tricks that brilliant filmmakers and novelists, and short story writers, and playwrights use are themselves also magic tricks that also take advantage of these features in the way that people work. So when we dissect them, we can discover very, very reliable aspects of those tricks turn out to be very important clues about the way that people think. Now, there are many kinds of surprises in narratives, and at the most basic level, you can have someone jump out from behind a wall and scream at you, and that's one kind of surprise, and it's scary. But in some ways, you are focused on a different kind of surprise, a more sophisticated
事实上，认知科学中有一个蓬勃发展的子领域已经意识到，魔术是发现视觉感知局限性和注意力方面问题的肥沃土壤，魔术师们几十甚至几个世纪以来一直在利用这些。而杰出的电影制作人、小说家、短篇小说作家和剧作家所使用的技巧，本身也是魔术，它们也利用了人们思维方式中的这些特征。因此，当我们剖析它们时，我们可以发现这些技巧中非常、非常可靠的方面，结果证明它们是关于人们思维方式的重要线索。现在，叙事中有许多种惊喜，在最基本的层面上，你可以让某人从墙后跳出来对你尖叫，这是一种惊喜，而且很吓人。但在某些方面，你关注的是另一种惊喜，一种更复杂的
kind of surprise. What kind of surprise is that? Yes, so I'm especially looking in this study at surprises where what you thought was happening, what you thought was going on, what you thought the circumstances were in a story turn out to be something different and that you're convinced by the story that it was something different all along. So that it's this retrospective surprise where the rug is pulled out from under you, the tables are turned, you, instead of thinking that the story has told you one thing and now it's telling you something different, what is going on here. You believe that you were mistaken and that now you have a new understanding of what was going on
惊喜。那是什么样的惊喜？是的，所以在这项研究中，我特别关注那些惊喜，即你以为正在发生的事情、你以为的情况、你以为故事中的环境，结果却变成了别的东西，而且故事让你相信它一直都是别的东西。所以这是一种回顾性的惊喜，即你被“釜底抽薪”，局势被扭转，你不再认为故事告诉了你一件事，现在又告诉了你另一件事，而是想：这里到底发生了什么？你相信自己弄错了，现在你对之前发生的事情有了新的理解。
before. So we're going to take a look at two movies both of which in some ways are these finely executed plots with these as you call it these finely oiled traps that are embedded inside them. And the first one is M. Knight-Charmelon's The Sixth Sense. A dedicated psychologist, Malcolm Crowe, is working with a troubled child named Cole. And after much effort, the psychologist finally gets Cole to open up about what's bothering him. Let's listen to a clip.
所以我们将看两部电影，它们在某种程度上都是精心构思的情节，内部嵌入了你所说的“精心设计的陷阱”。第一部是M·奈特·沙马兰的《第六感》。一位敬业的心理学家马尔科姆·克劳正在与一个名叫科尔的问题儿童合作。经过多次努力，心理学家终于让科尔敞开心扉，说出了困扰他的事情。让我们听一段片段。
I want to tell you my secret now. OK. I see dead people. I'm gonna tell you my secret now. I see dead people. In your dreams? While you're awake? Dead people like engraves and coffins. Walking around like regular people. They don't see each other. They only see what they want to see.
我现在想告诉你我的秘密。好的。我能看到死人。我现在要告诉你我的秘密。我能看到死人。在梦里吗？当你醒着的时候？死人，就像在坟墓和棺材里一样。像普通人一样走来走去。他们看不到彼此。他们只看他们想看的东西。
They don't know they're dead. Vera, tell us about the surprise that follows. Yes, well, so as I expect most people at this point, no. What happens is that the psychologist who's helping this boy who can see dead people come to grips with his gift and so on is himself one of these dead people who can't see the other dead people who doesn't know he's dead that's his reality. And of course this movie has long been held up as a power gone of the surprise ending for
他们不知道自己已经死了。维拉，告诉我们随之而来的惊喜。是的，好吧，正如我预料的那样，大多数人此时都知道了。发生的事情是，这位正在帮助这个能看到死人的男孩面对他的天赋等的心理学家，他自己就是这些死人中的一员，他看不到其他死人，他不知道自己已经死了，这就是他的现实。当然，这部电影长期以来一直被视为惊喜结局的典范，原因
precisely the reasons you just laid out which which is as you watch the movie, you are taken in and at the point at which the surprises reveal to you, you look back and you see the numerous clues that was scattered throughout the movie, including in this last clip by the way, where a cold the child says, you know, they're everywhere I see them all the time. And of course, Cole is actually talking and seeing someone who actually is dead. That's exactly right. And part of what happens is, you know, in all kinds of stories, having characters with different kinds of information about what's going on gives the story a justification for leading the viewer to pay attention to certain things and not pay attention to other things.
正是你刚才所说的，当你观看这部电影时，你被带入了进去。当惊喜向你揭示时，你回过头看，会发现散布在整部电影中的无数线索，顺便说一句，包括在最后这个片段中，孩子科尔说，你知道，他们无处不在，我一直都能看到他们。当然，科尔实际上是在和一个真正已经死了的人说话并看着他。完全正确。而且发生的一部分是，你知道，在各种故事中，让角色拥有关于正在发生的事情的不同信息，给了故事一个理由，引导观众去关注某些事情，而不去关注其他事情。
And we're inclined to forget or lose track of possible discrepancies between characters' perspectives. So in the sixth sense, we lose track of the fact that Cole knows things that other characters may not know and he sees things that other characters may not see and that we're seeing what he sees. I wanna spend some time exploring different elements
我们倾向于忘记或忽略角色视角之间可能存在的差异。所以在《第六感》中，我们忽略了科尔知道其他角色可能不知道的事情，他看到了其他角色可能看不到的东西，而我们看到的是他所看到的。我想花点时间探讨这些情节的不同要素
of this plot and how they might reveal things about our minds. We actually had Danny Coniman on Hidden Brain recently and he talked to me about the availability bias, things that spring more readily to mind are seen as more plausible than things that spring less readily to mind. Now most of us find it easier to bring to mind a psychologist who's dealing with a patient
以及它们如何揭示关于我们大脑的事情。我们最近在《Hidden Brain》节目中请到了丹尼·卡尼曼，他和我谈到了可得性偏差，即更容易浮现在脑海中的事情被认为比那些不容易浮现在脑海中的事情更合理。现在，我们大多数人觉得更容易想到一个正在处理患有幻觉的病人的心理学家，而不是一个孩子能与死人交谈的场景。所以一个场景看起来更有可能，可得性偏差愚弄了我们，让我们忽略了不太可能的场景。没错。当然，这些对我们来说更容易获得的场景，也因为电影本身而变得更容易获得，因为我们有一个角色在那里，那个心理学家，他
who's suffering from hallucinations rather than a scenario where a kid can talk to dead people. So one scenario seems more likely, the availability bias fools us into ignoring the less likely scenario. That's right. And of course also the fact that these scenarios that are more available to us are also made more available to us by also made more available to us by the film itself because we have a character there, the psychologist who is
绝对是在他不是死人的假设下运作的，他是一个活着的心理学家，他正在用这些东西帮助这个孩子。作为比最初评估的更严重的病理，患有视觉幻觉、偏执、学校恐惧症、精神分裂症。而这个关于正在发生什么的假设对我们来说非常容易获得，因为它也直接呈现在屏幕上。电影中还有另一个时刻利用了我们思维中的一个强大局限。由布鲁斯·威利斯饰演的已故心理学家马尔科姆·克劳正坐在房间对面
absolutely operating on the assumption that he's not a dead person, he is a living psychologist, he's helping this child with things. As pathologies more severe than initially assessed, suffering from visual hallucinations, paranoia, school AIDS, schizophrenia. And this hypothesis about what's going on is very available to us because it's presented to us directly on screen as well. There's another moment in the movie that takes advantage of a powerful limitation in our thinking. Malcolm Crow, the dead psychologist played by Bruce Willis, is sitting across the room
面对那个问题儿童的母亲。他们在客厅里，我们假设他们刚刚进行了一次困难的私人谈话。母亲低着头，她从不看心理学家。她甚至没有承认他在那里，这结果是一个非常重要的细节，但我们现在还不知道。然后，她的儿子走进房间。她起身去看他。嘿，宝贝。他今天怎么样？现在这一切发生得非常快，但让我们回到这个细节，母亲从未
from the troubled child's mother. They're in the living room and we assume they've just had a difficult, private conversation. The mother is looking down, she never looks at the psychologist. She doesn't even acknowledge he's there, which turns out to be a very significant detail, but we don't know that just yet. Then, her son enters the room. She gets up to see him. Hey, baby. How was he today? Now all that went by really fast, but let's return to this detail that the mother never
看过马尔科姆·克劳。我们认为她没看他是因为她对他们进行的谈话感到心烦意乱，但实际上，母亲看不到他，因为他是个鬼魂。作为一个死人，心理学家也没有注意到任何奇怪的事情。根据他角色的内在逻辑，他只是坐在那里，看着他想看的一切。他们只看他们想看的东西。他们不知道自己已经死了。问题是，我们自己也没有注意到任何奇怪的事情。
looked at Malcolm Crow. We think she didn't look at him because she was distraught about a conversation they'd had, but really, the mother can't see him because he's a ghost. As a dead guy, the psychologist doesn't notice anything strange either. According to the internal logic of his character, he just sits there, seeing whatever he wants to see. They only see what they want to see. They don't know they're dead. Here's the thing, we don't notice anything strange ourselves.
得出关于正在发生什么的结论，我们假设电影中的角色正在看到、听到和思考我们所看到、听到和思考的东西。就维拉而言，这个盲点，即想象别人像我们一样思考，这是所有盲点之母。认知科学家称之为“知识的诅咒”。所以我们知道的事情，我们发现很难，你知道，基本上不可能在思考别人可能知道什么时完全抑制这些知识。
Relief to a conclusion about what's going on, and we assume that the characters in the movie are seeing and hearing and thinking what we see and hear and think. As far as Vera is concerned, this blind spot, imagining that other people think like we think, this is the mother of all blind spots. Cognitive scientists call it the curse of knowledge. So the things that we know, we find it very difficult, you know, essentially impossible to fully suppress that knowledge when we're thinking about what other people might know.
它会渗入并影响我们对他人视角的推测。所以当我们第一次遇到这个场景时，我们对它可能意味着什么有了一个理解，并且我们很容易将这种理解投射到我们对场景中两个角色所想、所知和所理解的推测上，这影响了我们如何解读他们的行为。你知道，在阅读你的书的背景下，我发现这部电影的另一个非常可爱的地方是，它利用了我们如何对世界得出隐含结论。所以在电影的开场场景中，你不记得你自己的病人了吗？
It seeps in and colors and influences our speculation about the perspective of other people. So when we first encounter this scene, we have an understanding of what it probably means and we readily project that understanding onto our speculation about what both of the characters in this scene think and know and understand and this affects how we interpret their actions. You know, one of the other things I found really lovely about the movie in the context of reading your book is that it plays on how we draw implicit conclusions about the world. So in the opening scenes of the movie, don't you remember your own patients?
我们看到心理学家被一个前病人枪击。你找到我了！你只是给我一个机会。啊！啊！当我们过了一段时间看到他走来走去时，我的名字是马尔科姆·克劳博士。我们本应今天见面，但我错过了我们的预约。
We see the psychologist get shot by a former patient. You found me! You just give be a chance. Ah! Ah! When we see him walking around sometime later, my name is Dr. Malcolm Crowe. We're supposed to meet today, but I missed our appointment.
我们假设他康复了，而实际上他是个鬼魂。现在，没有人告诉我们他幸存了下来。我们甚至没有有意识地去想它。这些信息之所以强大，是因为它实际上是隐含的。我们只是没有注意到我们的大脑是如何在我们的意识之外不断且一致地跳向结论的。没错，当然，这就是我们一直在这个世界上导航的方式。这就是我们理解彼此讲述的故事的方式。
We assume he's recovered when in fact he's a ghost. Now, no one tells us he survived. We don't even think about it consciously. The information is powerful because it's actually implicit. We simply don't notice how our minds are constantly and consistently leaping to conclusions outside of our conscious awareness. That's right, and that's, of course, how we navigate the world all the time. It's how we make sense of stories that we tell one another.
我们留下了很多隐含的材料让别人去填补。我们不觉得必须对每一个连接点都费尽心思，把这些事情说得非常清楚，但同样真实的是，当我们行走于世时，我们对所遇到的事情、我们所处的环境、别人所想、所知或所打算的事情只有部分信息，而作为一个人并流畅地穿行于世界的部分本质，就是编造所有这些推断来弥合我们所确定的知识之间的差距。关于《第六感》，我还有一个最后的想法想探讨。你知道我们都认为我们理解
We leave lots of material implicit for other people to fill in. We don't feel like we have to be labor over every point of connection and make these things abundantly clear, but it's also true as we make our way through the world all the time we have only partial information about what we're encountering, what kind of situation we're in, what other people think or know or intend, and part of the essence of being a person and moving fluently through the world is conjuring up all of these inferences to bridge the gaps between what we know for certain. There's one final idea I want to explore in connection with the sixth sense. You know we all think that we understand
信息或我们通过仔细收集和处理所有证据来理解世界。但实际上，我们从某条信息开始，然后在此基础上构建。但这条初始信息在某种程度上就像一个锚。它影响了我们之后学到的所有其他东西。告诉我关于锚定效应及其在《第六感》中扮演的角色。嗯，是的。所以实际上，你提到了这个初始场景，对吧，他被枪击的地方，
information or we understand the world by carefully amassing and processing all the evidence. But in reality, we start with some piece of information, and then we build on it. But this initial information acts in some ways like an anchor. It influences everything else we learn afterwards. Tell me about the anchoring effect and the role it plays in the sixth sense. Well, yes. So actually, you refer to this initial scene, right, where he shot,
但紧接着是一个切镜头，切到他之后走来走去。所以你确实做出了这个推断，正如你所说，可能甚至没有注意到这根本就是一个推断。看起来电影好像向你展示了一些东西。它最初这样做，然后在电影的早期场景中反复这样做，你一次又一次地得到心理学家对正在发生的事情的理解。有了锚定，即使你对这种框架持怀疑态度，你立刻得到它的事实也会倾向于限制你想象力的方向。但你的倾向是把你设定的关于环境的初始框架作为你的锚，然后从中调整并试图说，嗯，也许不是完全那样，
but it immediately followed by a cut to him walking around afterwards. So you have this moment of inference that you make indeed, as you say, without probably even noticing that it was an inference at all. It seems as if the film has showed you something. And it does this initially, and then it does it repeatedly over the course of the early scenes of the film, where you're given the psychologists understanding of what's going on over and over again. And with anchoring, even if you're skeptical about this framing, the fact that you got it right away will tend to constrain the directions in which your imagination goes. But your inclination is to have that initial framing of the circumstances that he sets forth as your anchor and then to adjust away from it and try to say, well, maybe it's not quite like that,
但不是完全抛弃它。这就是让锚如此强大的原因，即我们认为我们愿意重新评估它，把它扔掉，抛弃它。但事实上，即使我们愿意这样做，锚仍然对我们施加某种影响，并阻止我们漂移得太远。没错。当然，这就是红鲱鱼（误导信息）的本质。即使是一个红鲱鱼，即使你看出它是一个红鲱鱼，即使你完全没有被那个红鲱鱼所暗示的推测路线所吸引，它仍然会对那些容易浮现在脑海中、对你可用的推测产生一种引力。当我们回来时，我们将看另一部20世纪90年代的电影，它也以其令人瞠目结舌的情节转折而闻名。《非常嫌疑犯》。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我正在与维拉·托宾交谈，她是世界上第一批研究情节转折如何为人类思维运作提供窗口的认知科学家之一。作为她研究的一部分，她花了很多时间看电影，寻找一种特定的惊喜。
but not to throw it away altogether. And so that's what makes the anchor so powerful, which is we think that we are open to re-evaluating it, to throwing it aside, tossing it aside. But in fact, even when we're willing to do that, the anchor still exerts some kind of influence over us and prevents us from drifting too far away. That's right. And this is, of course, the essence of red herrings in general. It's even if a red herring, even if you see that it's a red herring, even if you are completely not taken
惊喜，即它们在电影结尾高潮处出现，并推翻了之前的一切，所以你知道，大的情节转折。她称这些转折为“釜底抽薪”。在这一部分，我们将审视现代电影中最伟大的“釜底抽薪”之一。1995年的《非常嫌疑犯》。告诉我你从纽约把那个瘸子带进来了。他提到凯撒·索泽了吗？谁？
in by the line of speculation that that red herring suggests, it still will exert a sort of gravitational pull on the kinds of speculation that will come readily to mind that will be available to you. When we come back, we look at another movie from the 1990s that's also famous for its jaw-dropping plot twist. The usual suspects. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Today I'm talking to Vera Tobin, one of the world's first cognitive scientists, to study how plot twists can offer a window into the workings of the human mind. As part of her research, she spent a lot of time watching movies, looking for a particular kind of surprise.
在电影中，警察正在寻找一个名叫凯撒·索泽的神秘罪犯。我们所知道的关于索泽的几乎所有事情都是通过电影的叙述者过滤的，一个名叫“口头”（Verbal）的跛脚小混混。他由凯文·史派西饰演。在场景中，“口头”告诉调查员关于凯撒·索泽的传说。他应该是土耳其人。有人说他父亲是德国人。从来没有人相信他是真实的。从来没有人认识他，或者认识任何直接为他工作的人。
Surprises where they come climatically at the end of a film and they overturn everything that went before, so you know big plot twists. She calls these kinds of twists, rug pullers. In this segment, we're going to examine one of the greatest rug pullers in modern cinema. The usual suspects from 1995. Tell me you got the cripple in there from New York. Did he mention Kaiser Soze? Who?
但听小林说，任何人都可以为索泽工作。你永远不知道。那就是他的力量。所以情节转折是“口头”就是凯撒·索泽。而情节转折的另一部分是，我们所看到的整个展开的故事，即“口头”讲述他所发生的事情的叙述，看起来像是对过去神秘事件的一种直接倒叙。麦克马纳斯带着工作来找我们。芬斯特弄到了货车。
In the movie, the police are looking for a mysterious criminal named Kaiser Soze. Nearly everything we know about Soze is filtered through the movie's narrator, a limping small-time crook named Verbal. He's played by Kevin Spacey. In the scene, Verbal tells an investigator about the legend of Kaiser Soze. He's supposed to be Turkish. Some say his father was German. Nobody ever believed he was real. Nobody ever knew him or so anybody that ever worked directly for him.
波克尼提供了硬件。我提出了怎么做，所以没有人被杀。但是基顿。结果发现这只是他为了争取时间逃跑而编造的一个故事。我们都知道这可以做到。我计算出的做法意味着杀人，要正确地做需要五个人，五个人意味着基顿。
But to hear Kobayashi tell it anybody could have worked for Susie. You never knew. That was his power. So the plot twist is verbal is Kairzor Sosa. And the other part of the plot twist is that the whole unfolding story that we've seen as Verbal tells his account of what happened that appeared to be a sort of straightforward flashback to the mysterious events of the past. McManus came to us with the job. Fenster got the vans.
我想知道为什么我们在这里被误导，部分原因是由于我们采纳了向我们讲述故事的人的信仰和世界观，而讲述故事的人塑造了我们看待故事的方式。完全正确。所以发生的事情是，叙事越具有沉浸感，我们就越倾向于采取
Pockney supplied the hardware. I came through with how to do it, so no one got killed. But Keaton. Turns out to all have been just a story that he was spinning in order to buy himself time in order to escape. We all knew it could be done. The way I figured to do it wrong meant killing, to do it right took five men, five men meant Keaton.
一些人所说的“参与式视角”，也就是说，我们有这种沉浸式的体验，我们的视角开始越来越与叙事所描绘和呈现给我们的视角保持一致。当然，你可以在各种电影中看到这一点，即你从受害者的角度讲述电影，它就变成了一场悲剧。你从劫匪的角度讲述同一个关于银行抢劫的故事，它就变成了一个，你知道，潜在的有趣故事，甚至是一个关于抢劫成功完成的胜利故事。
I wonder who are misdirected here partly because we adopt the beliefs and worldview of the people who narrate the stories to us, and the person who tells the story shapes the way we see the story. That's exactly right. So what happens is the more immersive a narrative is, the more and more we tend to take
故事的视角，故事的叙述者，在塑造我们对什么是真实、什么是虚假的思考中确实起着核心作用。在那一刻，我不害怕。我知道我没做任何他们能对我做的事。此外，这很有趣。我得假装我很出名。事件的框架及其重要性，以及哪些部分值得关注，它们意味着什么，所有这些都是故事讲述方式和讲述故事的人的视角的一部分。而且再次强调，这一切大多是无意识的。
what some people have called an inactive viewpoint, which is to say that we sort of have this immersive experience and our viewpoint begins to align more and more with the viewpoint that's being depicted to us and presented to us by the narrative. And of course you can see there's in all kinds of movies which is you know you tell the movie from the point of view of the victim, and it becomes a tragedy. You tell the same story about a bank heist from the point of view of the robbers, and it becomes, you know, potentially a funny story, or even a Victoria story about a heist pulled off successfully.
我们实际上并没有在想，这是视角，这是我正在采用的框架。正如你所说，当一个好故事开始展开时，我们只是被卷入其中，然后，在某种程度上，我们的批判能力被搁置了。没错。所以故事越是情感投入、越是引人入胜和生动，我们就越少关注故事的装置，越少质疑、怀疑、保持警惕和监控这些关于“我应该信任这个来源吗？”的问题。
The point of view of the story, the narrator of the story, plays really a central role in shaping how we think about what's real and what's not real. At that point, I wasn't scared. I knew I hadn't done anything they could do me for. Besides, it was fun. I got to make like I was notorious. The framing of events and their significance and what parts are worth paying attention to and what they mean, all of these things are part of the way that the story is being told to us and the viewpoint of the person telling the story. And again, this is all mostly unconscious.
这里的差异是什么等等？你只是沉浸在那个视角中。当然，这意味着如果你是一位艺术家，创作电影或写书，你想做的是利用这样一个事实：在高度情绪化的环境中，人们比在其他情况下更容易轻信。没错。
We're not actually thinking, this is the point of view, this is the frame I'm adopting. As you say, when a good story starts to unfold, we just get swept along and then, in some ways, our critical faculties are put on hold. That's right. So the more emotionally engaged, the more gripping and vivid the story is, the less attention we're paying to sort of the apparatus of the story and questioning and wondering and being on guard and monitoring these questions about, should I trust this source?
所以我认为在很多情况下，人们倾向于认为情节转折在某种程度上与沉浸式叙事、生动的人物刻画、深度和复杂性等其他文学和电影价值相对立，它们是噱头，它们在某种程度上是反其道而行之的，但实际上它们往往利用的正是这些东西。你知道，当我读你的书时，维拉，我开始思考《非常嫌疑犯》是如何利用我们对“口头”有同情心这一事实的，因为他有残疾。在我们的头脑中，很难看出一个要求我们同情的人也可能是一个精神病患者，在某种程度上，这需要一种同时持有这两个对立观点的复杂性，这太难了，以至于我们只是抛弃了其中一个。
What are the discrepancies here and so on? You're just immersed in that perspective. And of course, then that means that if you're an artist, creating a movie or writing a book, what you want to do is take advantage of the fact that in highly emotional settings, people are more likely to be gullible than in other situations. That's right.
嗯，是的，所以刻板印象可以以这些方式被利用，事实上，这是故事框架的一部分，对吧？所以，你知道，“口头”有脑瘫，或者他看起来有，对吧？但作为他走进城市、跛行消失等最后场景的一部分。所以这个想法是，这个角色利用了人们往往倾向于认为身体残疾或其他刻板脆弱性的人在某种程度上没有资格担任其他角色这一事实，他也正在利用这一点。魔鬼曾经玩过的最伟大的把戏就是让世界相信他不存在。就这样，他消失了。
And so I think in a lot of circumstances, people tend to think of plot twists as being in some way opposed to, you know, their gimmicky, their operating on a level that is counter to these other sort of literary and filmic values of immersive storytelling, vivid characterization, depth and complexity and so on, but actually often they capitalize on exactly those things. You know, as I was reading your book, Vera, I got to thinking about how the usual suspects also takes advantage of the fact that we have sympathy for verbal because he has a disability. And it's difficult in our minds to see that someone who demands our sympathy might also be a psychopath that in some ways it requires a certain complexity of sort of holding these two opposing ideas simultaneously that is so hard to do that we just sort of jettison one of them.
你知道，心理学家有时会谈论后见之明偏差，即一旦事件展开，你会觉得你一直都知道它会发生。在某种程度上，一旦你在《第六感》或《非常嫌疑犯》中看到揭秘，你回过头看，你的一部分会因为没看出来而责怪自己，但你的一部分也会说，是的，当然，我实际上确实看到了所有这些事情。我实际上，这对我来说确实有意义。是的，你可以说服自己处于这样一个位置，你说，哦，是的，你知道，我，我，我半信半疑，你知道，我，我是在轨道上，比你实际上可能的情况要多，对吧？所以所有这些
Well, yeah, so stereotypes can be taken advantage of in these ways, and in fact that's part of the framing within the story, right? So, you know, verbal has cerebral pals palsy and or he seems to, right? But part of the final scene as he walks out into the city and his limp melts away and so on. So the idea is that the character was taking advantage of the fact that people often tend to see people with physical disabilities or other kinds of stereotyped vulnerabilities as somehow not eligible for other kinds of roles and that he's capitalizing on that as well. The greatest trick the devil ever pulled was convincing the world he didn't exist. And like that, he's gone.
都有助于，向你推销这个想法，即故事确实公平地对待了你，线索就在那里，事后是可以猜到的。YouTube上有一个十几岁的男孩在沙发上第一次观看《第六感》结尾的片段。拍摄他的人无法抑制他的兴奋。别看你的手机。就看那个该死的……当沙发上的孩子得知电影的重大秘密时，他经历了几个阶段。困惑……
You know, psychologists sometimes talk about the hindsight bias, which is once an event has unfolded, you feel like you knew all along that it was going to happen. At some point, once you see the reveal in the sixth sense or the usual suspects, you go back and there's a part of you that kicks yourself or not seeing it, but there's a part of you that also says, yes, of course, I actually did see all those things. I actually, this actually makes sense to me. Yes, you can talk yourself into this position where you say, oh, yes, you know, I, I, it was, I halfway oh yes, you know, I, it was, I have way believed that, you know, I was, I was on the track, more than you really were potentially, right? So all of this
等一下。理解？天哪！然后他带着一种完全欢欣的神情转向镜头。而那个拿着摄像机的人，他欣喜若狂。呵呵呵呵。就好像他是第一次看到这个惊喜一样。呵呵。那么这里发生了什么？
helps to, to sell you on this idea that the story really played fair with you, that the clues were there, that it was guessable after the fact. There's a clip on YouTube of a teenage boy on the couch watching the end of the sixth sense for the first time. The person filming him cannot contain his excitement. Don't check your phone. Just watch the fucking... As the kid on the couch learns the movie's big secret, he goes through a few stages. Confusion...
为什么故事中的惊喜让我们如此高兴？维拉说有几个原因。一个是，毕竟，这确实是一个故事，而不是现实生活。所以这种对惊喜刺激的安全探索，没有现实生活中可能使惊喜变得如此不愉快的潜在结果。所以，你知道，这就是为什么去坐过山车真的很有趣，而从悬崖上掉下来却没那么有趣的部分原因。对吧？另一个原因是，当它们构建得很好时，在现实生活中，你并不一定
Wait a second. Understanding? Oh my God! Then he turns to the camera with a look of total glee. And the guy with the camera, he's euphoric. Hehehehe. It's as if he is seeing the surprise for the first time. Hehehe. So what's going on here?
有这些突然惊喜的铺垫，你可以回顾之前发生的事情，发现惊喜是具有启发性的，对吧？它为之前发生的事件赋予了新的、有趣的意义，但对于一个制作精良的惊喜，这已经为你准备好了。这有点像我们从解决填字游戏或难题中获得的乐趣。在某种程度上，看起来令人困惑的事情都各就各位了，看到所有部分如何完美地结合在一起有一种强烈的快感。完全正确。所以故事能为你做的是构建这种洞察力
Why do the surprises and stories leave us so delighted? Vera says there are a few reasons. One is, after all, it really is a story, not real life. So this kind of safe exploration of the thrill of surprise without the possible outcomes that would make surprises so unpleasant potentially in real life. So, you know, it's part of why it's really fun to go on a roller coaster and it's not so much fun to fall off a cliff. Right? And the other reason is that when they're constructed well, in real life, you don't have necessarily
体验，你感觉到的不是有什么东西让你措手不及，或者你只是被惊喜到了，而是这种感觉就像你对事情如何结合在一起有了真正的“啊哈”时刻。这是人类非常喜欢的东西。维拉·托宾是凯斯西储大学的认知科学家。她是《惊喜的要素：我们的心理极限与情节的满足感》一书的作者。维拉，感谢你今天参加《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢你的邀请。
a lead up to these sudden surprises where you can reflect back on what happened before and discover that the surprise is enlightening, right? That it lends new, interesting significance to the events that happened before, but with a well-made surprise, this has been set up for you. It's a little bit like the pleasure we get from solving a crossword puzzle or a difficult problem. It's at some point things that seem confusing all fall into place and there's an intense pleasure at seeing how all the parts come together beautifully. Exactly. So what a story can do for you is construct this insight
本周的节目由劳拉·夸雷尔制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、帕斯·沙阿和托马斯·刘。我们今天的主题引起了我的强烈共鸣，因为故事是我们经常在《Hidden Brain》中思考的事情。我们努力寻找能让研究和想法变得生动的真实故事，我们经常花几个月的时间来处理这些故事，以确保我们为你提供最有用的收获。如果你曾经从我们的节目中学到的想法中受益，请考虑在 donate.npr.org/hiddenbrain 进行捐赠。那个地址再重复一遍，donate.npr.org/hiddenbrain。你的捐赠将支持你当地的公共广播电台和
experience where you feel not that something has blindsided you or that you were just taken by surprise, but this experience that feels as if you have a real aha moment about how things fit together. And that is something that humans like a lot. Vera Tobin is a cognitive scientist at Case Western Reserve University. She's the author of the book, Elements of Surprise, our mental limits and the satisfaction of plot. Vera, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me.
我们的工作。谢谢，我们真的非常感激。我们本周的无名英雄是阿尔伯特·李。阿尔伯特帮助管理《Hidden Brain》的预算，他对细节的关注正是你希望在这个职位上的人所具备的一切。据说每家好企业背后都有一位伟大的会计师。在我们的案例中，这绝对是真的。谢谢你，阿尔伯特。那么你怎么看？你喜欢达斯·维达实际上是卢克父亲的事实吗？是的！不！我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。
This week's show was produced by Laura Quarell and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Parth Shah and Thomas Liu. Our topic today resonated deeply with me because stories are something we think about a lot at Hidden Brain. We work hard to find stories that bring research and ideas to life, and we often spend months working on those stories to ensure that we are providing you with the most useful takeaways. If you have ever benefited from the ideas you've learned from our show, please consider making a gift at donate.npr.org slash hidden brain. That address again is donate.npr.org slash hidden brain. Your donation will support your local public radio station and
这是NPR。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
our work. And thanks, we're truly grateful. Our unsung hero this week is Albert Lee. Albert helps to manage the budget for hidden brain and his attention to detail is everything you would want from someone in his role. It's said that behind every good business is a great accountant. And in our case, that's certainly true. Thank you, Albert. So what did you think? Did you like the fact that Darth Vader was actually a loomstad? Yeah! No! I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR.
我们的工作。感谢你们，我们真的非常感激。本周我们默默无闻的英雄是阿尔伯特·李。阿尔伯特负责管理《隐藏的大脑》的预算，他对细节的关注正是你对这个职位的人所期望的一切。俗话说，每个优秀的企业背后都有一位伟大的会计师。在我们的案例中，这绝对是真的。谢谢你，阿尔伯特。那么你觉得怎么样？你喜欢达斯·维达实际上是一个卢姆斯塔德（loomstad）这个事实吗？耶！不！我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。
And this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。